si les fêtes de fin d'année approchent
louis burton n'était pas en vacances ces
derniers jours le skipper évinois de 35
ans a été victime de multiples varie ses
problèmes techniques l'ont poussé à se
mettre à l'abri du vent pour réparer son
bureau vallée 2 et s'est réfugié à
proximité de l'île macquarie pour
effectuer des réparations
c'est le bout du monde
si vous voyez bien le bateau ça ça fait
partie des trucs les plus les plus hard
que j'ai fait de ma vie
le navigateur donc maintenant on va
descendre sans se casser la figure
on va renvoyer la chine et on va le
mettre
aujourd'hui tout va bien louis burton
est en 11e position et remonte sur les
autres skippers le navigateur peut
commencer à se projeter sur les fêtes de
noël il a notamment eu une pensée pour
les téléspectateurs yvelinois
[Musique]
suivez depuis quelques années maintenant
les séries
faire pour moi je vous souhaite de
bonnes fêtes
la course s'est très très bien passé sur
la première partie jusqu'à la deuxième
position
la route est encore longue prenez soin
de vous joindre soit condamné julien
dray le jour de noël louis burton
ouvrira les cadeaux de ces enfants ces
derniers lui ont glissé des surprises en
son bateau avant le départ le 25
décembre il dégustera un bon plat au
menu du foie gras avec des toasts et une
bouteille de vin